[Music]  this is our best chance to find a  habitable planet  we breed and raise our own crew  three train them in isolation  to prepare them for life and space two  the voyage will take 86  i'm years of what  there's nothing to be scared of  you are the link between past and future  generations  and have been entrusted with the  survival of our species the normal kids  sensitive and smart i need to protect  them  there she talks into the water it's  coming from us  we're eating something toxic  it's the blue it's medication to  decrease  pleasure i'm not drinking it  what does it feel like to feel something  restarting  we won't ever see the planet i want to  be honest with him  about everything he can't protect you  protect us from that  i'm scared there's nothing to be scared  you